hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well at the beginning
of meditation 6 Rene Descartes is going
to draw a vital distinction between two
different faculties of the human mind
both of which we hopefully use quite
often although perhaps some people only
rely on one of them which can get them
into trouble and those are the lower
Faculty of imagination and the higher
Faculty of what he calls here pure
intellection or conception now this
actually corresponds to what in in other
places he's been calling the intellect
or understanding the on Tom to mom and
you know there's going to be a vital
difference between these that we're
going to see emerge in this before we go
into that we should think a little bit
about what he means by this so the
imagination is this faculty by which we
picture things or we we engage in you
know either spontaneously or
deliberately putting things together in
such a way that we can frame them in our
minds and we do so not necessarily just
through visual images but we might
imagine sounds or odors or tactile
sensations for example if I tell you
right now to amay
a pink elephant you're able to do that I
imagine and now imagine that you're
going up to the elephant and touching
its side and you feel its skin and
surprisingly it's so soft its hairs are
soft its skin is soft and kind of giving
in well that you've done a some
visualization but not just visualization
you've also done we might call it
tactile ization as well that's
imagination right intellection is going
to be something a bit different and so
Descartes is going to tell us early on
that if I consider closely what
imagination is I find that it's nothing
other than a certain application of the
Faculty that knows two bodies that are
intimately present to it and therefore
that they exist this is where we're
going with this that's the upshot of
that but first he says we really need to
think about what the difference between
imagination and pure intellection and
conception is so he says let's do
geometry here imagine a triangle not
hard to do right you just kind of draw
three lines in your head or maybe you
just popped it into your head right now
so that's one way of grasping what a
triangle is as a matter of fact we can
put one right here on the board right
here is a nice little triangle in case
you're having trouble imagining it you
can just look at that one right there so
he says when I imagine a triangle
I don't conceive only a figure composed
and comprised of three lines but but you
know beyond that I consider these three
lines like as if they're present by the
force and an inner application of my
mind I think of them I place them here
in my mind and he says that's properly
what I call imagining but what I want to
think of and here he brings up a term
that you're probably not familiar with a
killing on alright what is it killing on
well it comes from the Greek word 4000
right a thousand sided figure try to
imagine that now try to bring before
your mind a figure that has a thousand
sides I dunno if it has a thousand sides
did you just put together in your mind
something that is a whole bunch of sides
and it's almost like a circle and maybe
it's actually like a hundred sided
figure maybe it's a thousand in one
sided figure unless you can actually
count them in your head which is very
very tough to visualize you're not sure
that you actually have a killing on
there he says when I want to think of a
kill agon I can easily conceive of the
truth that it's a figure composed of a
thousand sides as easily as I conceive
of a triangle is a figure composed of
three sides but when I try to imagine
the thousand sides of a Killa Gong like
I do with the three of a triangle
to think of them as present with the my
the eyes of the mind what happens
he says following the custom that I have
to use my imagination all the time when
I think of corporeal things it happens
that in conceiving of a Killa gonn I
represent within my mind
he says a figure that is confusedly
representing this right confusedly as a
problem why because that's the opposite
of distinctly I need to have clear and
distinct ideas for Descartes
right but I don't have a clear and
distinct idea of a Killa God in the
sense that I imagined it I can't I can't
have a clear and distinct idea when I'm
going away from the senses going away
from diagrams and just conceiving of it
thinking about its properties when I'm
using this higher part of my mind and
going away from trying to picture it so
he says that it's you know very evident
that this figure is not a killing on
since it doesn't differ at all from what
I would represent if I think of a Miriah
GaN or some other figure with many sides
so this doesn't help me to discern what
the properties are of the Gilligan what
about if I think of a Pentagon well
that's a little bit easier right can you
imagine a Pentagon sure picture you know
one of those things on the soccer ball
there's hexagons and pentagons on soccer
balls or just think of the Pentagon
think of the the place where we have the
US military command and all that other
sort of you know bureaucracy surrounding
them or any other five-sided figure you
like make it square and add two more you
know lines right substituting for the
one line not hard to do now conceive of
the Pentagon and think about how many
degrees it has to have do you remember
that equation from back in algebra or
geometry when you are studying
many-sided figures triangle has 180
square has 360 and you can go on from
there well that you're using your
intellect you're not actually using your
imagination and so he says that when we
consider a Pentagon we can easily you
know do it with the the imagination but
we can also conceive of it without the
aid of the imagination I can't imagine
it he says I can bring it to the
attention of my mind
each of these five sides and the space
that they they contain and then I can
conceive clearly that I don't actually
have any need of the imagination in
order to do this as a matter of fact the
imagination in some respect requires a
little bit more effort he talks about a
particular contention and it's that in
the French and in the Latin needed to
imagine the
pentagons and this he says shows us one
of the key differences between
imagination and intellection so here's
what it consists in very interesting
idea the imagination he says is not
actually necessary or essential for the
human mind now all of us do have an
imagination and you might say well if
it's not essential then why do we have
it it's not essential for us to know the
properties of geometric objects as a
matter of fact sometimes it can get in
the way like it does with the killing on
so it's it's an an on it's a surplus
he says it depends this shows us it
depends on something other than
something distinct from my mind what is
that something you know he's actually
gonna say it's bodies there is another
possibility maybe it's ideas in God's
mind or something like that but he gets
rid of that idea you know it's the
external world and the body through
which we encounter that external world
that's the a non it's not essential to
our mind imagination if it's essential
at all it's essential to the composite
of mind and body takes in information
coming from the senses and from the
storehouse of memory and works with
those things and allows us to picture or
imagine things intellection however is
he says necessary and essential to my
mind it's absolutely essential it's what
we've been doing throughout the entire
course of the meditations think about
how we begin we engaged in this
hyperbolic doubt we put aside anything
that what might arrive through our
senses or our imagination or our memory
and we made recourse to thinking about
the nature of the mind itself the mind
he says conceives itself by turning
towards itself it doesn't do it through
imagination when it uses the imagination
to try to
picture itself it screws things up this
is why we need to separate intellection
from imagination and the senses what it
does is it considers its own ideas now
he goes on a little bit further and he
says that I conceived easily that the
imagination can be of this sort if it is
true that the body or body in general
exists that there is body quite
literally in the French either you're a
right sort of the conditional of the
yeah there is something exists so this
is going to allow him to say that we
actually do have an external world in a
body we're gonna get there eventually
there is one other thing that's worth
pointing out and this comes later in the
discussion of the faculties he says that
I find inside myself faculties of
thinking that are quite particular and
distinct from me that is the faculties
of imagining and sensing without which I
could in fact conceive clearly and
distinctly myself entirely but not only
can I think of myself with thinking not
only can they they be thought different
than me right but they can't be thought
without a substance intelligent that
they are attached to so something like a
mind how are they attached to the mind
this is where we get to the mind-body
connection and he says that the notion
that we have of these faculties or to
use the terms of the school in their
concept their formal concept they
include a certain kind of intellection
from which I conceive that they are
distinct from me like figures movements
and other modes or accidents of bodies
are from the body themselves which
sustain them so we have a really
interesting realization here I have an
imagination
you have an imagination all of us have
imaginations but our imaginations are
separable from us they're not really
what we are insofar as we're thinking
substances there are add-ons they're
extras there's surpluses and they are
precisely that because we are in fact
Minds joined in some way that Descartes
doesn't explain here to the body we have
the imagination only because we have
bodies and thereby can start to picture
and imagine and make use of the senses
to understand things so we have to be
very careful to distinguish these apart
from each other because when we're
thinking about the nature of the mind
itself we don't want to try to imagine
it we want to do what Descartes has been
doing and that is to understand the mind
through conception or intellection the
use of the Faculty of understanding
rather than the Faculty of imagination
you